good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody hope everyone's looking
forward to the weekend
weekend it is thrive day here at our new
york studio because theo is in studio
with me i figured you know it's friday
let theo have a little a little fun
you're quite chipper given the grave
news of yesterday oh [ __ ] i forgot like
you're allowed to be
chipper you're you know i do think
that's what the queen would want you are
you chipper shaming me she would want
the show to go on because i don't know
if you guys know this but the queen was
a toaster
um yeah yeah and she's not around to
deny it so no
was that insensitive no no the queen
would have wanted that for us no the
thing is like i have insurmountable
respect for the queen i'm not like a
queen hater i don't i actually don't
think anybody could question or
challenge like our love for the queen
our our loyalty to the monarchy for a
country in which we do not reside
so i just think that this is our way of
grieving like thinking about the queen
listening to the toast making it about
us she's literally up in heaven
listening to the toast well we had this
conversation before like i think she saw
our halloween episode
i hope honestly like she didn't
we were viral queens
no i um i don't know if she caught that
episode i do think she became a toaster
later than that
um
but that's the thing about becoming a
toaster like it happens to you at
different stages of your life but it's
it's just as meaningful no matter when
it is impactful
so
you be chipper i think that we need that
energy today
it's friday and i am a human being so i
you be chipper it's just also
a somber day
no i totally forgot i can't lie like
i've just i had a busy morning not to be
the influencer like that we talk about
but i did get my period and like i'm in
so much pain it's like a bad one you
know when you think like oh if this had
been the month i got pregnant i would
have had quintuplets you know yeah okay
so now we all know thank you we needed
to know that information about you
i want to be octo mom or tan mom um tan
mom
yeah because
carrying that many um fetuses at once is
not
healthy it's like a risk it's very high
risk
so yeah no i don't want to be actual mom
i just like want to be famous you know
i'll take what i can get you're on your
way
that is so nice of you you're so famous
to me
you're the most i say i thought you were
going to end that sentence after you're
so famous you're the most famous person
i know
hmm is that true
no
let me think about my competition who do
you know like who do you think we know
the it depends how you define no
yeah you're the most famous person i
text with
do you find affair
oh my god okay um yeah so today is an
extremely sad day here at the morning
toast yesterday i think we we thought we
might be having this conversation
relatively soon the news broke one or
two hours after we wrapped the podcast
and you know what i'm glad that it
didn't happen
in the middle of the show like i'm glad
that we've had time to kind of sit with
it because honestly like i did not
expect to be like as affected and as
emotional by all the tributes that have
poured in
for miss elizabeth yeah everybody is
real i mean most people really had so
much respect for her
so much admiration
and you know where i wasn't expecting to
find
such um
beautiful words but one tribute that
like really got to me
was from khloe kardashian yes
she was just like you know the world is
always changing and change is so scary
but the one thing that we've all always
had and been able to rely on is this
constant is like the monarch the queen
is the monarch and just to have that
change is like crazy and it's scary and
honestly like yes she was our stagnant
queen literally yeah she was the
constant and it does feel a little
uncertain
you know and i i do feel like
it is the end of an era but it couldn't
come at a stranger time you know
yeah and there's also just like so much
going on within the family right that
there's so many other things to consider
but the thing is there's always so much
going on within the family like if you
really think about it there's so many
different people personalities there's
always some drama think about the crown
like yeah it was never gonna be like
everybody is happy to see each other
but the way that things went down
yesterday i thought was really
interesting
and i thought it was bizarre it was
bizarre so here's what i think happened
yesterday i think and i think this is
kind of confirmed like she passed hours
before they announced it yes they said
that they were going to be announcing
something at 1 pm eastern time i think
it was like 6 o'clock
uk time
and we all like were tuned into the
television streaming i was trying to get
a license for bbc tv like 10 minutes go
by 20 minutes it's almost 30 minutes and
then no one comes out to say anything
and instead the royal family posts on
instagram the announcement
so which is very new media of them but
like for the platform to be instagram
where i feel like for these types of
announcements it's always to the bbc
yeah no i thought that they would come
out and announce it someone would like
speak to us and let us know what had
happened
i feel like not everyone got there on
time and the news was already like
circulating that she had passed and they
just had to get it out because
they couldn't wait any longer right are
you saying like harry was taking his
time because there were photos of him
like arriving after the announcement had
already been made to balmoral he arrived
after the announcement i don't know if
they were waiting for him but i just
feel like the timing just got away from
them and they were like yeah instagram i
feel like that's just like how it
happens with death like you think you
have like you think you know and then
like things happen and people's health
declines and like it just happened so
fast yeah but he was in the uk
yeah yeah it's not like he was coming
from l.a
which is like a coincidence
right that was a bizarre coincidence
also interesting that megan was with him
in the uk and she did not go to balmoral
yes but what i read from the daily mail
is that earlier that morning they were
they were leaving their hotel or
whatever together she was going to go
with him then pictures came out that
kate was still at windsor
because she was taking her kids to
school and so then i think
megan decided not to go
oh my god megan is definitely having
like ptsd flashbacks like from like
being everything like kate does like the
comparing well i mean if if kate's not
gonna be there then it's not appropriate
in the hierarchy yeah yeah yeah no i i
get it um it's just sad that they can't
like text each other and be like girl
are you going instead of share a jet i
have to wait for the paparazzi pigs to
like see where you are it's like their
version of you know like instagram
stories find my friends yeah
totally
so it wasn't necessarily the most
unexpected news but it's just still so
sad and now all the things that happen
after are gonna be really interesting to
watch yes so we have a lot of news about
yesterday and the queen
and i think without further ado we
should jump right in um because i have
nothing i do want to say else to share
my day was somber it was raining all day
here it was raining usually there's
always like a rainstorm every few days
it's 20 minutes
all day rain
god was crying
we were all crying there's a beautiful
day here though
well
dad was also smiling
100 after 70 years of a gorgeous loyal
monarchy yeah
so without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
visa do you ever dream of starting
something game changing well then visa
can help make it happen maybe it's
creating and selling your own customized
sneakers maybe it's transforming your
dorm room into a plushy pop-up shop or
finally going mainstream with your side
hustle for us it was starting a morning
show that literally
changed the world change the world
whatever you're bold enough to try visa
has the power to help bring your game
changing ideas to life visa anyone can
change the game
great thank you for that our first story
queen elizabeth the longest reigning
british monarch has died at the age of
96. her historic 70-year reign has come
to an end
excuse me for a second queen elizabeth
ii one of the most iconic figures of
both the 20th and 21st centuries has
died quote the queen died peacefully at
balmoral this afternoon buckingham
palace announced in an official
statement on thursday the statement
continued quote the king and the queen
consort will remain at balmoral this
evening and will return to london
tomorrow charles has returned to
king charles cavalier spaniel has
returned
there's only one king charles in my life
yeah there's three but
the news of queen elizabeth's death
comes with another history-making moment
she succeeded immediately by her eldest
son prince charles 73 who will now be
the monarch charles's firstborn son
prince william is now next in line to
the world's most famous throne followed
by his firstborn son prince george
now i know we all knew like charles was
next in line but i think in the back of
everyone's head there was like a little
like glimmer of hope that queenie was
leaving a note behind being like get my
son away from the throne like yeah so
even though this was literally what's
supposed to happen there was no way
around it
i can't be the only one who was like
when they saw the announcement i'm like
the king and queen consort charles i was
like
yeah
and
they announced it so quickly like
thereafter there was a letter from his
majesty the king it was charles so there
was no questioning like oh who's gonna
be next like he is now king charles yeah
she didn't leave that note for us and
given that she didn't i actually am
feeling more open-minded towards charles
than i thought that i would because up
until yesterday like i believed he was
nothing of the sort like i really don't
like like
he's not for me
um
but now knowing like this is what the
queen wanted and maybe she'd had the
authority to usurp him
but this is what she wants charles is
king that's how she left it and i think
it's
we have to respect the queen and accept
no of course except him as our king here
in america in america i've never been
alive for like a passing of the throne
so i don't know if this is just a
general feeling you have whenever
there's a new monarch but it's just like
i don't see it you know like he's just
not getting the king he's not kingly
that's the problem with him like and in
the words of patricia altschule like
he's lived an inelegant life
and it's hard to see him in that way now
in a regal kind of like i can't imagine
anyone listening to him he does not feel
authoritative at all he's like the
person whose opinion at like the family
dinner you literally ignore
yeah
yeah they did a picture of him did you
see the picture of him in his royal garb
like on the chair
yes it wasn't the worst picture
so his mom dies and he runs to the
throat to take a photo like they already
had that one i think it was an old photo
because he does look
a little younger fresh
yeah and i don't really understand how
these things work that like you know
philip was a prince and camilla who is
like a scandalized woman is a
queen consort yeah so in february
remember the queen put forth a statement
that that would be her wish that
camilla would have the title of queen
consort
you know what after all they put that
woman through
camilla deserves the title like they
couldn't just let them get married when
they liked each other because like a
husband who cares no because she wasn't
a virgin she wasn't married yet
i can't and yeah that's the thing like
people don't like camilla because of
like her role in the and in the diet
andrew in the charles and diana thing
um
but honestly it's none of those people's
faults it's the
parents faults who like didn't let them
be together and honestly charles and
camilla their story is kind of
extremely romantic it's like all of
these years charles was with so many
different eligible women he could have
had anyone it's like it was always
camilla
no totally and like it's we we have to
talk about it while like eliminating
diana from the conversation because her
life was [ __ ] ruined yeah
but they really never should have let
him marry anyone else because he wasn't
the type of royal who was born like
understanding that this was his duty and
like willing to forgo all the things
that he wanted in life because he was
born in this place he want he wanted
what he wanted and he wasn't going to
give up on it so you know what like i do
actually feel like charles and camilla
like are still deeply in love it's like
a win that's a testament it's a win to
romance but it's not a win for duty
no no but you know what she's done a
good job and they should have just let
her have the job from the very beginning
like there was no reason they had to be
all sneaky and bring diana in and like
all this stuff yeah but i personally
like don't hold on against camilla
no me neither even though like she was
being like a jezebel but you know what
the heart wants what it wants
now
what's interesting and i was thinking
about this last night is because harry
is now a direct
um
offspring of the monarch his children
will become princes and princesses if
they so choose to give their kids that
title
and it just makes me think because i'm
like a conspiracy theorist and there is
like a a
very widely believed conspiracy that
allegedly charles is not harry's father
his father is james hewitt if you've
seen a photo of james hewitt he's
literally harry in 10 years it's crazy
um
which would now just be so crazy because
let's say that conspiracy like let's
let's live inside that conspiracy that
would mean like harry and megan like
literally have no relation to the
monarchy like so their brother is next
in line but that's it
that's relation to the monarchy
not to the monarch
yeah well that's actually our next story
a guide to the royal family's new
official titles we're going to tell you
how everything changes now
and i just want to say i know you're
like still like working out your tick
tock thing but you absolutely need to
get it back on tick tock and follow this
girl she's a brunette american girly
with glasses i'm so sorry i don't know
her name she explains everything that i
know everything you're about to say okay
let me um
oh oh my god i just opened tick tock on
my ipad because i have it here and the
first one is like about how
queen elizabeth is going to be
reincarnated as trisha paytas baby
yes i did hear that trisha went into
labor um as the announcement was being
you know made um their rumors she's
named her child elizabeth i don't know
if that's true or not um but i could
definitely see queenie coming back and
like finally being able to live yeah and
i think trisha paytas future child is
gonna live
yes i i don't hate that but i don't
think the timing matches up i think if
reincarnation is a thing it has to be
like this actually no the soul needs
time to travel across the pond plus
she's on the west coast
now can i ask you a question yeah
so if you were to be reincarnated
as another species like you can be a you
can't be kylie you know
what would you want to be reincarnated
as like an alien an animal what kind of
animal of sea mammal maybe a king
charles kepley or spaniel
totally
but like one that lives in the palace
yeah me yeah one of the corgis yeah
she's reunited with her corgis
i also wouldn't mind being a bird
why
flying
i would never have to like you know what
if flying for birds is like the
equivalent of running for humans
strenuous such a good question
however i don't think birds
possess like the emotional intelligence
just to hate exercise you know
but that's a very valid point i'll have
to look into that before i make my full
decision right like that's why some
birds take to the sidewalk
some birds just perch
i would be a percher i would be a
percher for sure on the telephone pole
yeah
okay sorry second story second story
everyone is moving on up titles are
changing here we go prince charles will
now be known as king charles iii
cavalier spaniel
um there was my girly on tick tock said
there was a lot of speculation that he
might not use his boy for his royal name
that's what they said because
because charles like in terms of the
monarchy has like a negative association
not him specifically just the name and
john the second and the first
right so um i guess he decided to you
know stick to his guns he's clearly like
not
into like sacrificing anything no but i
will say i think in the past monarchs
would change their name upon becoming
the monarch and do their royal name but
because charles is 73 years old it's
like who are you fooling we know you're
charles i feel like it's a little late
in life to go by something else i don't
know if that's the reason but just as a
lay person it works for me and the fact
that he is king charles does give him a
gravitas
that makes him more endearing to me it's
a strong name and like it's king charles
cavalier spaniel like i'm sold
do you think his like animal of choice
is going to be king charles kevin no
offense he's [ __ ] better like it's
now time
i'm prepared to embrace him but he needs
to start acting right
he needs to help us help him like he
needs to start acting right and he needs
to start acting like a monarch and not
just like doing whatever the [ __ ] he
wants like yeah
act right
act right that's so true make it easy
for us
and get a king charles
was elizabeth's born name elizabeth yeah
queen [ __ ]
queen [ __ ] but like that's a royal last
name yeah there was a queen elizabeth
the first so it could be done
next camilla will now be
queen consort
it's kind of like a stunning name it's
giving asmr queen
but why can't she just be queen
um
i don't know but again i don't know if
this is just something that happens when
it's a changing of the guards and in 10
years i'll be like yes so royal i don't
see either of them as like true royal
highnesses i just don't i know but they
do not possess the real energy that they
believe they do
i don't even think they believe they do
i know i think they're just like waiting
yeah but i'll give her a chance
yeah of course not an open minded girl i
never followed her closely like her
fashion or her work or anything but i'm
open
they came when they came back to london
this morning there was like thousands of
people outside buckingham palace
obviously
and they were very warmly received
yeah it's definitely like a weird part
of being royal where like you're given
no time to be human like literally the
man's mom died yesterday and he has to
have his photograph taken go out meet
with these random people like it's so
unnatural it is but he's 73 um he had
time to prepare as opposed to queen
elizabeth who was 26 years old
and
um
her father died suddenly and she did all
of it like with the utmost grace like
yeah no it's just like starting a new
job literally the afternoon that one of
your parents dies yeah yeah no it's
weird it's not a lot but this is a
chance for charles to rise to the
occasion yes and it's about damn time he
does rise yeah now prince william will
now go by um the duke and duchess of
cornwall and cambridge and he's also
expected to inherit the title of the
prince of wales which was charles's
title that's always but charles has to
give it like elizabeth gave it to
charles like it's something you have to
get okay and i think that he will like
that there's me too i know i think
willie and charlie have a good
relationship there's no reason why they
shouldn't and he will be
the heir and that's just what's done so
i'm gonna he'll be the prince of wales
and then that would mean kate would be
the princess of wales which
is very fitting
so elegant i wonder how she's doing yeah
i'm sure she's just worried about the
grand grandkids the grandkids you know
it's like their first brush
with death like it's like always feel
like we're too ex
oh right right they're pros at this
point yeah
now prince george is going to become his
royal highness prince george of the
cornwall and cambridge
so they just got nice they got cornwall
now they were always the cambridges but
yes now they've snatched up cornwall
princess charlotte princess charlotte of
cornwall and cambridge prince louis
prince louis of cornwall and cambridge
prince george is a great name
yeah
and he's really turning into quite a
handsome young man yeah no and he i mean
we don't know his personality yet but he
seems like he's got what it takes
he has that um
that energy that i think people
immediately saw that william had and
immediately saw that charles did not
yeah
it's like a regalness
that you just carry with you where it's
like you're clearly the firstborn you're
clearly you're rising to the occasion we
could see a future in which you are the
monarch and i don't think anyone really
ever felt that way about charles i feel
like he's just kind of been doomed from
the start well i think just because from
the start i mean we see in the crown how
he's like very emotional you know very
like what about me what about my
feelings like mommy mommy and it's like
girl
you're gonna be
he's like so privileged yeah and just
like
less rational more emotional than i
think throughout his life he's
constantly made decisions that he's
wanted to make as opposed to doing what
was like right and necessary as opposed
to his mother who literally never made a
decision for herself always for the
monarchy and i think that maybe william
would have ended up that way but i think
when he lost his mom like he really grew
up very fast and like immediately became
very kingly yeah he's very kingly
yeah and so is prince george then harry
and megan no new titles for them
um
but
archie and lillabet could become prince
and princess if charles decides to
bestow it upon them what would have been
interesting is like if there was never
this break within the family
i believe he would have given them those
titles
unless like you're saying he might not
be
the grandpa no i'm telling you what
happens with archie and lullaby will be
really no but now everything and
everything can be blamed on the split
yes that's true and also if they if
let's say our harry has no relation to
charles and they know this
they're going to do everything publicly
to cover that up they're not going to be
like
yeah snubbing people with titles yeah
but i think that um they prop and also
as far as megan and harry are concerned
i think that they would say that they
don't want the titles for their kids
right isn't that why they moved to the
stage and like when archie was born they
um
offered him a title the earl of
dumberton it was a courtesy title and
they declined it they had said like they
wanted him to be prince because the
grand grey grandkids of the monarchs are
prince and princess but that's actually
not true it's the grandkids of the
monarch are all prince and princess if
you think of which is why they're now
eligible right but they were they
actually were not eligible when the
queen was the monarch but i think to us
lay people were like yeah why aren't
they prince and princess right right
well the thing that i just find
confusing about the harry and megan
thing is like when they did step back
like what that meant
because
i think they have the titles and name
only i don't think they're allowed to
like use the titles but i see the titles
everywhere yeah like duke and duchess
have said yeah when harry goes back to
the uk today it's like the sussexes are
back together right no but like even i
feel like in their work like
i feel like in her podcast like they
call her the duchess of sussex let me go
look i actually was trying to find their
instagram yesterday because i was
wondering what they
i think it's sussex house
really
no i don't know i literally just made
that up
okay
yep archetypes introducing archetypes
are refreshing and dynamic new podcast
where megan the duchess of sussex dives
into
right the labels that try to hold women
back
oh you mean like the label they just
used
um i i just got confused when they
stepped back
as to like i feel felt like their titles
became even more prominent
after they left
yeah no it's like
it's like a flex for sure i mean like no
but like countess luanne take it all or
nothing is really like you know
walk the walk talk the talk like they
get all of the like privileges of like
being real
they don't have to deal with their
responsibilities and they can like do
netflix spotify as they please disney
etc make the money
yeah they don't have to i just thought
like the titles were gone and now i've
honestly like when they were royals i
literally didn't even know their titles
yeah
yeah no the the titles are
not in terms of colloquially socially
so i don't know if they're going to
embrace the potential title of prince
and princess for their kids or reject it
because i honestly don't i really don't
have they haven't been clear on what
their vibe towards titles is yeah agreed
i don't know either down
don't get me wrong somebody offers theo
a prince dumb like you bet your ass
we're marching up to the palace and
taking it yeah i feel like it's like
they're it's not about like titles yes
or no it's like well what's the title
like we're not we don't care about the
earl of dumberton
um yeah i mean we will not a great title
the earl of dumberton would you rather
have
no title or be
the earless of dumberton
is it earlx yes
i think um well think robert grantham
was an earl right
so what was cora dowager no no no
dowager is means
cora cora was a
she was a lady lady earl's wife
orioles wife title
earl's wife is aunt pearl not too shabby
countess of dumberton are you gonna take
it
dumberton i mean yeah i'm taking
anything
and also maybe it's just like an
american thing but when i think of earl
i literally think of like a balding like
potbelly
like uncle earl from yeah montana yeah
but that's just me okay but like would
you take a girl for
how old is archie two three years
until you become friends could you do a
hold over earl
it's we're playing a long game here yeah
yeah of course no i would take it
yeah same and i also think to reject a
title is just like kind of rude
a little it's like here would you like
this diamond bracelet no thanks no i'll
wait for the bigger one
yeah right it's like a little it's like
a little bird it's a little small that
one so we're just gonna have to watch
like how did i put my ipad down we're
like so far from done
we're gonna have to watch see how
charles does i'm open-minded i'm not you
know
my expectations are low
yeah but i'm really feeling like this
tabula rasa vibe where it's like okay i
can maybe
not forget but like compartmentalize
how you spent the last 73 years let's
see what you do starting today and if
you want to conduct yourself in a regal
manner
yeah
and then our third story is just one
more queen story because a rainbow
appeared over buckingham palace shortly
before queen elizabeth's death was
announced
a double rate double raymond a double
rainbow broke through the clouds over
buckingham palace in london on thursday
shortly before the death of queen
elizabeth ii was announced buckingham
palace said the queen died peacefully at
age 96 at belmoral castle in scotland on
thursday afternoon crowds were gathered
outside the royal residence in london
amid concerns about the monarch's health
when the rainbows appeared so going by
what we said if it was a few hours
before the announcement she was likely
already passed and this rainbow very
likely was her i mean i'm a
i'm a spiritual person already but even
something like this i'm like whoa
i'm like especially in a town like
london where in order to make a rainbow
you need the sun and the sun does not
shine in london and it's like the queen
is a divine being
you know if you go back to the beginning
she's the leader of the church of
england and she's a godly figure and so
now seeing this i'm like
maybe she is no totally
um
there were just so many things like so
many things that happened so many things
that people shared that were really like
emo like i saw this poem i sent it to
you last night i didn't know if you were
sending it to me to
because it was sweet or because like you
were laughing
you think i would laugh at this i don't
know that like just some kind of monster
seriously you think i'm a monster but i
thought it was i said how sweet
i thought it was so beautiful let me
read it it is really beautiful
phillip came to me today and said it was
time to go i looked at him and smiled as
i whispered that i know oh my god i'm
literally going to cry
i then turned and looked behind me and
seen i was asleep all my family were
around me and i could hear them weep
i gently touched each other with philip
by my side then i turned away and walked
with my angel guide
philip held my hand as he led the way to
a world where kings and queens are
monarchs every day
i was given a crown to wear or a halo
known by some the difference is up here
they are worn by everyone
i felt a sense of peace my reign had
seen its end
70 years i had served my country as the
people's friend i'm not okay
thank you for the years for all the time
and love now i am one of two again in
our palace up above
source sweet source unknown
source unknown the person posted on
instagram stories and was like i found
this on facebook like but it's really
beautiful
rip
okay i have to say
i um i definitely saw a little bit less
of the like the disrespect for the dead
that i saw with olivia newton john
um
like i didn't see people singing the
queen's songs you know like if anybody
posted like a song it was really
beautiful no one was like rip queen
it was like i saw a little bit of ripped
queen but a little a little but i will
say new and john it was so obvious and
at least people were capitalizing rip i
think it's because with the queen
there's like more things that you can
say like god save the queen
long may she rain yeah stuff like that
whereas when it's a lay person it's just
like rip
rip i don't give a rip
people are
literally not okay
literally not okay but i will say i have
thoroughly enjoyed my whole instagram
feed being queen too
um
and just seeing really who the queen of
files are out there that i follow no and
like the impact of a person who
literally nobody has met like nobody i
saw on social media but i've never met
also love seeing all the celebrities
that she's met over the years like who
is big enough to meet the queen yes i
actually watched this
stunning video from the chief rabbi of
israel he had a very good relationship
with queen she was extremely supportive
of the community i love that for her and
if charles doesn't follow in her
footsteps like not my king
no
literally he's not
yeah if i'm charles like i'm going back
at looking at the last 70 years page by
page and any time a decision comes to me
i go and see what queen did
i mean
it's all that needs to be done the
playbook is this
is not in a great spot let me tell you
why one everyone hates him and thinks
he's totally inept
two he's literally feeling the big like
he could not be following in the
footsteps of a more universally loved
and respected monarch yeah
it's really he could do his absolute
best and it's all downhill from here
it's just
it's very hard no and also a few weeks
ago like news came out that he accepted
money from osama bin laden's family did
you see
that
what yeah hold on i pulled it up it said
he accepted a million dollars from osama
bin laden's um half brothers in 2013
to his prince of wales charitable
foundation
okay at least it was for charity that's
better like let's be real
no it's not great it's not great yeah so
it's just
yeah he's a little messy messy king yeah
um but
i think it's he has an opportunity ahead
of him i don't want him to like think
it's all the history books are written
like it's never too late to turn it
around to start a new i couldn't agree
even three years old like you're able to
change
100
long may he rain
long may he rain
and that's to be young our queen
recap
uh the tribute i'm sure we'll continue
to come in this weekend this funeral
will be in a few days the brits have
like a seven day morning period i don't
think they have to work which it's
giving shiva it's giving shiva which is
so sweet
everyone just needs to really
take the time
think about the queen honor her in
whichever way they see fit
yeah and you know what's so crazy is
like how invested we feel and we're not
even british and we're certainly not
catholic but if you're a british
catholic like this is crazy no they are
at the palace
yeah you're outside the palace like
wailing yeah
you're the princess of whale
queen
i miss her already
i'm so ready too but you know what like
i'm so happy for her like her life was
hard no and it's like it was long and it
was hard and it was full of
treacherousness but
it's like
job well done like she goes out and it's
like you
aced it queenie like she no she gets an
a plus from everyone an a plus for life
for reigning like
i don't know who she answers to up there
but they're like not nary a bad remark
yeah i just like
i i obviously i'm sad she's gone but i'm
also like extremely happy for her like
she finds peace yeah her life was hard
yeah
literally remember that man like
literally came in and sat in her bed i
know and she was like what's up girl
she was so calm and you know what if you
do not watch the crown now would be a
great time i'm actually i wish i like
never watched the crowd i think it's no
don't say that because i only like my
royal respect love everything started
with the crown
before the crown i didn't watch william
and kate's wedding i literally probably
couldn't tell you
who her kids were who's what's the it
sparked an interest in me that like for
the last
five years or whatever like i've been
able to enjoy the queen while she was
alive imagine watching it now like i
missed all of this i missed it history
was happening every day and i missed it
a hundred percent but you could
definitely rewatch it i'm sure it'll be
number one on netflix this weekend
yes
and the crown was filming in spain and
they're taking six weeks off of filming
they were filming the diana car crash
scene so they're just pausing
yikes
yeah
yeah
so that's the queen uh news we'll now
get into some of the other mindless
synod news of the day but um
we'll come back to her
and um
the rest of the show is brought to you
by zocdoc battleship is a fun board game
that a lot of us played as kids but as
an adult calendar battleship is the most
frustrating game you play with your
doctor trying to find when you're both
free for an appointment like in three
months but with zocdoc booking an
appointment with a doctor that suits
your needs is easy zockdoc is a free app
that shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance and are
available when you need them on zocdoc
you can find every specialist under the
sun whether you're trying to straighten
your teeth fix your achy back get a mold
checked out or anything else zocdoc has
you covered their mobile app is easy
as order it's as easy as ordering a ride
to a restaurant or getting delivery to
your house you'll search and find and
book doctors within a few taps find and
review local doctors you can read
verified patient reviews from people who
made real appointments now when you walk
into that doctor's office you're all set
to see someone in your network who gets
you go to zocdoc.com toast and download
the zockdoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today many
are available within 24 hours that's
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash toast
zachdock.com
toast
great okay our next story kylie jenner
and kris jenner went on james corden's
the late late show on thursday and they
were answering a bunch of questions
making headline news including what's
your baby's name though kylie still
isn't ready to share
so
kylie still isn't ready to share her and
travis's seven-month-old son's name
since changing it from wolf but the
reality star did just drop a major in uh
no she didn't while speaking to jamie
into james corden she said that she has
not officially legally changed the name
it's still wolf on his passport but that
isn't going to be his name quote we're
just waiting and simmering we don't call
him wolf
she added that she's not ready to share
yet because travis often thinks of cool
names and changes the moniker again
but james advised her to zone in on one
and she replied that we have uh when he
asked her whether the name is still
animal themed she replied no so that's
the major hint
okay do you know about the conspiracy
theory about us
uh no i saw something that people think
that i was maybe that was that we know
the name and we accidentally dropped it
on a breaking bread episode and like
covering it up
literally it was like three days after i
went out to a club with stars and
they're like stars told claudia and
claudia knows the name and claudia told
jackie and jackie accidentally dropped
it but then they covered it up yeah
no it was live um
but
it's true we uploaded it we could have
edited it out it's true what can i say
you call it yeah jackie had said that
the baby's name was knight which a lot
of people think
yeah that's why i said it and that's
what i think of his name when i think i
don't think of him as wolf i think of
him as night because i just saw it so
many times but then also i literally
don't even think of him because he
doesn't have a name so like he's not
even in my brain but it's because us
told you and that's how he knew right
right yeah no because we know because we
know for sure um i'd love that for us i
i will i can either confirm nor deny
these rumors i just feel like it's
important to let everyone know jackie's
being sarcastic i don't know if they can
read we don't know anything can't
confirm or deny but how cool do people
think we are like just knowing things
and also like we would if we knew we
would say no we wouldn't
we actually
if i knew i would be like i feel like
the name is xander
and then it'll be xander claudia how did
you know it's a pet it would yeah it
would depend how you found out if it was
someone who's like confidence you
wouldn't betray
you wouldn't do that if you like found
out from
by the way what if the name now is
xander i could see it no i could see it
too
because it starts with an x and like she
was doing a w before yeah i just i can't
confirm or deny these rumors what can i
say
yeah no for sure
i like how james corden is becoming the
new ellen like just celebrities who like
like him and trust him go on his show to
like be mindless right so there was more
stuff from the episode chris and kylie
are there i believe promoting their new
kylie cosmetics collab it's another
chris collection part two all about like
martinis and elegant living
diamonds
and chris also took a lie detector test
where she was asked many a question
including is kylie your favorite
daughter yes the lie detector determined
that was true
she was asked if she liked courtney's
wedding dress
chris said yes the lie determine
detector determined that was true
she was asked if kylie skips too many
family commitments she said yes the lie
detector determined that that was true
she was asked if courtney's travis's pda
is too much i believe she said sometimes
and then the lie detector determined
that was false
all the time yeah i'm just going based
on my memory here so just she was asking
was it the classic the classic lie
detector man he didn't look familiar he
wasn't lisa vanderpumps guy she was
asked if kim ripped the marilyn dress
she said no the lie detector determined
that was true
oh
yeah i can't remember what even though
like i like how we all just like believe
lie detector tracks detector tests when
they're
literally have been found proven to not
be legit yeah
yeah i don't i feel like it was all
planned before she's not actually going
to take like
it was all planned but it was
entertaining and i could see them doing
that whole little she was asked if she
sold kim's sex tape she said no the lie
detector determined that was a lie
i'm kidding
the lie detector determined that was
true that she did not yeah i just could
see them putting together that segment
to address one thing and then putting
like cushioning questions like about
courtney's dress and [ __ ] like literally
just to address the
marriage like
chris came with a knife and said lie
detector man you'll say these things are
true yeah yeah
hundred percent yeah but still so we
still don't know how baby's name kylie
looked gorgina beyond
like i'm like really entering my chris
era like i am a chris i if i honestly
could steal the wardrobe the decor the
everything of one of the girls it would
be chris
yeah
chris is like like coastal grandmother
billionaire yeah no i'm really like i
love the three i love kylie chloe and
kim like
yeah chloe's like chloe's like
everything they're all
but chloe's been doing a lot for me
these days this my top is good american
code jackie 20. they tend they dmg i
have one two claudia 20. yeah 20 off
either of our codes but jackie 20 is the
one you want to go yeah no it's jackie
20 is spelled
c-l-a-u-d-i-a and by the way we make no
money off of this we're just like
thirsty wenches c-l-a-u-d-i-a-2-0
at goodamerican.com the set that i wore
to funny girl um
was from a good american everything i
own is from good american and honestly
shout out remy bader got me so into good
american i was like definitely sleeping
on it because i don't really like to
wear jeans
um and they literally barely even sell
jeans like they literally sell
everything else too yeah but i just want
to say jackie's actually less letters
than claudia so you probably just want
to go with jackie 20 for brevity's sake
yeah and so if you guys are wondering
how that's spelled it's
c-l-a-u-d-i-a-2-0
or you can place split your order in
half do one with jackie 21 with claudia
20. you know i use jackie 20. i don't we
don't even get anything out of this
promo code so fine use your jackie 20 i
don't [ __ ] care you think i care you
think about the [ __ ] care
jackie 20.
um fifth and final story are you ready
for it
i was literally born ready the people of
venice are on their feet again because
on it armist oh my god these people
stand up for anything received a 14
minute 14
ovation in venice after streaming or
premiering her movie blonde streaming
which is where she plays marilyn monroe
andrew dominic's blonde debuted to a
massive 14-minute long standing ovation
during its world premiere at the 2022
venice film festival anna de armas who
plays marilyn monroe was in tears at the
screening her place glowing as tears
streamed down her face
i guess
yeah
like um
even the best movie i've ever seen i
probably wouldn't stand for more than 10
seconds and that's probably just because
i'm getting the popcorn off my lap like
i can't imagine a movie
being that good especially no offense if
it's like about marilyn monroe like
she's a queen for sure but like i don't
know her
14 minutes is just a long time and
that's awkward as [ __ ] like all these
videos that are coming out like brendan
fraser is a pee job so like i didn't
feel awkward but like watching the
animal arms one it's just like it's like
when people sing you happy birthday like
what are you supposed to do yeah also at
this point like if your movie doesn't
receive a standing ovation like it must
be embarrassing absolute trash
embarrassado like seriously because
they're standing up in venice for anyone
also brad pitt is a producer on this
movie and it's just a ship make me [ __ ]
it's just making me [ __ ] but have you
heard the rumors about brad pitt and
emily radakowski
know what that they're like dating that
was from honestly she gives angelina
vibes like in terms of her looks so he
obviously has a type
um and i don't chip i don't chip maybe
it's just because i'm jealous i i would
ship sufficiently but i prefer this
pairing even though no one said they're
together he just like took a picture of
her because he worked on the movie
um also adrienne brody was there with
his girlfriend georgina chapman georgina
chapman
uh obsession doesn't even begin to
describe the way i feel about georgina
chapman and adrian brodie like what a
miserable life she had for so many years
being married to like this disgusting
slob
um and to now be out and about with like
this hot jewish man
i'm sure she's getting [ __ ] down in
venice like i'm so happy for her like oh
to be young not georgina chapman getting
[ __ ] down in venice she deserves it
she's getting digged down in venice like
she deserves it get your dick girl like
i love that for you yeah so
marilyn movie looks good adrian bruno
he's a good kid he's a good kid
what's that from
no he's like a good kid
but how are you calling him a kid when
he's like your father because he's like
a good kid you know okay
um
also i just feel like i can't talk about
adrian birdie without talking about the
time that i was seated next to him at a
dinner party and had legitimately no
clue who he was and i was like what do
you do
because everyone at the table was famous
you know mariah carey was there i'm like
oh they obviously sat me next to like
the other not famous person
two losers and he's like i'm an artist
i'm like like you paint
he's like yeah i have like a studio in
soho you should come by and i'm like i
would love that i'm like i'm never gonna
see this loser again
and then he laughs and someone was like
how hot is adrian brody i'm like adrian
brodie's here
they're like he was
literally sitting next to you
and i felt like like the worst jew in
the world
you botched it you squandered your
chance you wanted mrs adrian bernie
could have been you well i couldn't have
because at the time i was a big-faced
molly [ __ ] and adrian birdie like
wouldn't have looked at me twice but now
i have adrien brody appreciates inner
beauty it just so happens he's dating
someone physically gorgeous yeah but i
think it's his inner beauty it's a
coincidence in her beauty he's after
yeah it's totally he's chasing after
that inner beauty um
that was that was tough for me like
that's one of those moments where like
you just also the time i didn't show up
at the shorty awards and i actually won
one
that was one of the moments like i just
want to literally kick myself yeah
that's bad
yeah and on the stream shea mitchell was
like girl with no job and then like
literally it was quiet
and you don't know why i wasn't there
because like i literally was sleeping
and i just like i was like i'm never
gonna win but i had rsvp'd yes i didn't
know it was like a real thing i thought
it was like a party yeah but shame
to you beyonce
big face witch of the west back then too
so you know what i'm glad i now don't
have to like watch a stream where i
accept an award with two moles on my
face you know
yeah sure not to make the marilyn monroe
movie about me right but
marilyn monroe movie marilyn i'll give
it a chance just no it's called blonde
yeah sure whatever
i'll give it a chance just because
that's the power of elvis
and what elvis did for me like just
embarking on this newfound journey of
like appreciation i would love to have
that moment with marilyn because
obviously she's a queen um
but i don't have a personal connection
to her yet
no me neither and i just feel like she's
like the type of icon who i would get to
know and find annoying you think
but i just like find women annoying
because i'm not a woman who supports
other women so maybe that's on me
we'll have to see but maybe ana's
armistice is gonna like make her
annoying and that's not fair
so true a lot of celebrities do that
like when they get the opportunity to oh
kristen stewart yeah diana but
i'm gonna have a bit of soup
oh could i could i go for a drive would
that be all right if i would drive
yeah like they make historical figures
in a wing and then you think of them
forever it's like oh diana that annoying
[ __ ] [ __ ] when it's actually kristen
stewart that annoying [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah even though i would like lay my
life out on the line for kristen stewart
for her work for her work it's
her contribution to cinema is
immeasurable
yeah
and i gotta read twilight
you do what are you gonna read this
weekend
oh i started uh another i've been on a
christina lauren kick even though like i
have dnr two of them like not every book
is for me but when i find one that's for
me like it's so for me but do you find
that when you read the same author over
and over like without taking breaks that
like you get so
in nerd to the way that they write and
like the similes that they use and like
[ __ ] like similes the similes yes but i
don't really find that i just find like
after i finish like i'll never read them
again and i hate them
yeah i was reading too many ellen
hildebrand books at one time and it's
like okay we get it you take the joke
her books are also really long
yeah but no i like i love her she's a
queen but i do need to break up my
favorite authors yeah yeah no i wanted
to stop doing christina lauren and i
went on like i went on tick tock i found
like all this recommendation i found
this i landed on a book and it just so
happened to be christina lauren it's
funny it was weird
um so yeah this weekend i have a
birthday party
i'm gonna see the counselor
center my regards william of course i
really just want to tell her the bunk is
asking for her the bunker the bunk is
jumping the bunk is uncounseled
and it shows hold on one second hold on
one second
talk oh about how the bunk has no
counselor
we are just campers flying by the seat
of our pants counselor snitch if you're
listening to this we miss you dearly
is that a doctor i see
theo is here to wish everyone a happy
friday hi my love has been why since
you've been on the show say hi to
everyone gorgeous
we're just wish everyone a happy friday
tell them to be safe to take advil
before they go to bed if they were
drinking
and doctor's orders you know get some
get some rest but also have some fun
yeah love that for you guys
read some books hopefully i finish my
book soon it's going slow it's good but
it's just like never ending
you're here but it's good we've all been
there i wonder what i'll read next we
shall see
um well if you're looking for something
to read girls no job.com book my memoir
was a new york times bestseller people
keep discovering it sending me messages
like didn't think i could love you
anymore but you're literally like gandhi
so if you are looking for a book that
that'll make you laugh cry
and just like love the toast even more
if it's possible girl with no check that
out
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
first monster by gandhia ashrae
totally
um and
if you're looking for something fun to
do next weekend in the pacific northwest
i will be in portland and seattle doing
my comedy show there's only like eight
shows left people are saying it's the
greatest comedy show ever written the
greatest show on earth those people are
related to me it's just important that i
make that distinction um or they have
been paid by me to say that but it's
still such a good time we're gonna have
spritz we're gonna be drinking with the
girlies it's gonna be a meetup of
toasters so i would love to see you girl
with no job.com tour
that'll be fun hope everyone has a great
weekend you know take the time to
reflect on queenie's life work whether
it's a book or a show i actually
probably my next book will probably be a
queenie related book so if i go do some
research i'll post them on my instagram
that look good
yeah welcome please do you're welcome
yeah anklet thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
monday morning show where we deliver the
first five stories every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have rated cast box all the places
wherever you listened to podcast find
nice morning shows leave a five star
view about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing weekend we love you and we'll
see you on monday bye